From WBEZ Chicago, this is This American Life, and I'm Ira Glass. The story that we bring you today is a kind of classic mystery story, but a classic mystery of a very particular kind. It's a real life Hardy Boys story, or maybe an episode of Scooby Doo.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天带来的故事是一个经典的悬疑故事，但却是一种非常特别的经典悬疑。这是一个现实生活中的“哈迪男孩”故事，或者说是“史酷比”动画片里的一集。
There's an old abandoned house. Some kids stumble upon it. They decide to break in. And then at that point, they kind of hit the jackpot kid-wise. The place is filled-- and I mean filled-- with fascinating stuff. It's also creepy and mysterious. And there are all kinds of tantalizing clues about what happened there, which they decide to uncover and which ends up taking years-- decades actually.
有一座被废弃的老房子，几个孩子偶然发现了它，并决定闯进去。那一刻，对孩子们来说，就像中了头奖。这地方满是——我是说装满了——令人着迷的东西。它同时又诡异且神秘。到处都是关于那里发生了什么的诱人线索，他们决定揭开真相，而这最终花费了几年，实际上是几十年。
We are devoting our entire show today to this one story, The House Near Loon Lake. We first broadcast this show in 2001. If you're in your car right now as you hear this, I hope you have a long drive ahead of you, so you can stay tuned. If you're at home and it's night, you might consider turning down the lights. Adam Beckman tells the tale.
我们今天整期节目都致力于讲述这一个故事，《卢恩湖畔的房子》。我们首次播出该节目是在2001年。如果你现在正在车里收听，希望你前面还有很长的路要走，这样你就可以一直听下去。如果你在家而且已经是深夜，你或许可以考虑把灯光调暗。亚当·贝克曼讲述了这个故事。
It was my brother's idea to go down to the lake. We brought an M80 firecracker, and we wanted to detonate it in the shallow water where we used to swim. We were 11, and it was late fall of 1977. We were visiting a place called Freedom, New Hampshire, a small town of a few hundred people, just across the border from Maine. My dad had volunteered to do some maintenance work at a summer camp I had once gone to.
是我哥哥提议要去湖边的。我们带了一个M80鞭炮，想在我们以前游泳的浅水区把它引爆。那时我们11岁，是1977年的深秋。我们当时在探访一个叫弗里登的新罕布什尔州小镇，那是离缅因州边境不远，只有几百人的小镇。我爸爸当时自愿去一个我曾经去过的夏令营做维修工作。
My brother Kenny, best friend Ian, and I went along. We'd been inseparable growing up. But now Kenny had started hanging out with an older crowd. And I'd been seeing less and less of Ian since I just transferred to a new school. I was in a funk about losing touch with Kenny and Ian. And so for me, the stakes for the weekend were a little higher than usual. In normal times, we like to go shoplifting or set things on fire.
我哥哥肯尼、最好的朋友伊恩和我一起去了。从小到大我们形影不离。但现在肯尼开始跟一群年长的人混在一起了。而自从我转学到新学校后，我见伊恩的次数也越来越少。因为和肯尼及伊恩疏远，我当时情绪很低落。所以对我来说，那个周末的重要性比平时要高一些。在正常情况下，我们喜欢去顺手牵羊或者放火烧东西。
That Halloween, we'd taken cans of WD-40 and gone from door to door, spraying it in the mouths of jack-o'-lanterns until flames burst out their eyes, and they blew up in balls of fire. This is my brother Kenny. He's now 37, and he's a scientist.
那个万圣节，我们拿着WD-40润滑喷雾挨家挨户地走，把喷雾喷进南瓜灯的嘴里，直到火焰从它们的眼睛里喷出来，然后它们就在火球中爆炸了。这是我哥哥肯尼。他现在37岁，是一名科学家。
I think Ian's mom used to worry a little bit about Ian spending too much time with us or being brought under our bad influence. Because I think we taught Ian about throwing woodchips at cars, and we taught Ian about unfolding paperclips so that you could shoot them at people and so on.
我想伊恩的妈妈过去常常担心伊恩跟我们待得太久，或者受了我们的坏影响。因为我觉得是我们教会了伊恩向汽车扔木屑，教会了他如何拆开回形针去射人等等。
So we were wandering around, looking for something to do. And we saw the house. It was gray, weathered, and leaning precariously at one end. The windows were boarded up from the outside. Two old cars, probably from the 30s, sat in the yard. One of them had a tree growing up through a hole where the engine had been. At the back of the house, we found a window that was broken, and I remember peering in into near darkness.
所以我们当时在四处徘徊，寻找能做的事情。然后我们看到了那座房子。它灰蒙蒙的，风化严重，一端摇摇欲坠。窗户从外面被木板封死了。院子里停着两辆旧车，大概是30年代的。其中一辆车的引擎位置长出了一棵树。在房子后面，我们发现了一扇破窗户，我记得曾向里面窥视，里面几乎一片漆黑。
I remember it was kind of a dare kind of thing.
我记得那是一种大冒险似的事情。
That's my friend Ian.
那是我的朋友伊恩。
It was one of these things where we just would say, you know, I'd go in that house. Wouldn't you? And you would say, yeah, I have no problem going in that house. And Kenny would say, yeah, that house looks fine. And none of us really wanted to go in that house because we're all scared. But we did.
当时的情况就是我们随口说：“嘿，我会进那间屋子，你敢吗？”你会说：“是啊，进那屋子我没问题。”肯尼会说：“是啊，那屋子看起来挺好的。”其实我们谁都不想进那屋子，因为我们都怕。但我们还是进了。
Ian was the skinniest, so it was decided that he should go in first. He slid sideways through the broken panes, so he wouldn't get cut, and disappeared. After maybe 10 seconds, he scrambled back out, clutching a newspaper. It was brown, and I remember it crumbled in our hands. The headlines said something about Nazis invading. That was all we needed.
伊恩最瘦，所以决定让他先进去。他侧身穿过碎玻璃窗，以免被割伤，然后就消失了。大概10秒钟后，他抓着一张报纸连滚带爬地出来了。报纸是棕色的，我记得它在我们手里碎掉了。头条标题大概是关于纳粹入侵的内容。这就足够了。
One by one, we climbed into the house. It was dark inside. The only light came in through little cracks between the boards that covered the windows. The floor felt soft underfoot. And as my eyes adjusted, I could see that it was covered with a layer of filthy clothes. Junk was everywhere.
我们一个接一个地爬进了房子。里面很黑。唯一的光线来自窗户木板间的缝隙。脚下的地板感觉很软。当我的眼睛适应了黑暗，我能看到地板上覆盖着一层肮脏的衣服。垃圾到处都是。
Actually, we couldn't walk around on the floor because you couldn't see the floor in most places.
实际上，我们无法在地板上走动，因为在大多数地方你根本看不到地板。
It was just jammed with more stuff than you could live with. Because I remember there were a couple of rooms you couldn't go into for how much stuff that was jammed in there.
那里被塞满了东西，多到让人无法生存。因为我记得有几个房间，光是里面塞的东西就让你没法进去。
I was careful to remember how we got in, in case we had to find our way out in a hurry. We were all very quiet. We'd seen enough horror movies to know that joking around could get us into trouble. Here's Ian.
我很小心地记住了我们是怎么进来的，以防我们需要快速逃离。我们都非常安静。我们看过的恐怖电影足够多，知道开玩笑可能会惹上麻烦。这是伊恩。
We did not spread out. We stuck probably almost hip to hip. And our backs were glued to each other. And Kenny was maybe looking the other way, and his back was kind of-- so we were sort of like this little star of people walking through the house. And Kenny is like one of the worst people to go into a situation like that with.
我们没有散开。我们大概紧挨着对方，背靠着背。肯尼可能在看另一个方向，所以我们的背……我们就像一颗小星星一样在屋子里走。而且肯尼是那种最不适合在这种情况下一起进去的人。
Why do you say that?
你为什么这么说？
Because he's very jittery. And he always will kind of mumble about maybe what the worst thing might be that might next happen. Like, I bet somebody is going to come out of that closet.
因为他很紧张，总是嘟囔着接下来可能发生的最坏情况。比如：“我敢打赌有人会从那个衣柜里跳出来。”
Some rooms were in total disarray, with things strewn about like they'd been rummaged through. But then there were these little areas where things were untouched. In the kitchen, dishes were stacked on open shelves. Pots and pans cluttered the sink. And the pantry was stocked with canned food. I picked up a container of Hershey's syrup, and it felt heavy. A salt and pepper shaker sat on the kitchen table.
有些房间一片狼藉，东西乱扔，就像被人翻过一样。但也有一些区域完好无损。厨房的开放式架子上堆着餐具。水槽里堆满了锅碗瓢盆。食品柜里储满了罐头食品。我拿起一瓶好时糖浆，感觉很沉。餐桌上放着一套盐和胡椒瓶。
The main sense I had was of disaster.
我当时最主要的感受就是灾难。
This is my brother Kenny.
这是我哥哥肯尼。
As if people had been kind of toodling along in their everyday lives, and something terrible had happened. Something catastrophic had happened to the people in the house, so catastrophic that no care had been put in arranging, or sorting, or editing any of the contents of their lives. And there was a feeling as we sat there that this time capsule hadn't been opened in 50 years.
就好像人们本来在过着平静的日常生活，突然发生了可怕的事情。屋里的人遭遇了某种灾难性的变故，以至于根本没人有心思去整理、分类或处理他们生活中的任何物品。当我们坐在那里时，有一种感觉，觉得这个时间胶囊已经50年没有打开过了。
Hanging in the kitchen was one of those calendars they give out at gas stations. It was dated December 1938. In the bedroom was a pile of shoes, maybe 30 high, that had fused into one mass. On a nightstand, I found a pair of eyeglasses folded on top of a man's wallet. And I slipped them both into my jacket pocket. In another room was a bureau, and tucked in the mirror frame was an invitation to a dance at the town hall. Pinned to it was a rose that was completely withered.
厨房里挂着那种加油站发的挂历，日期是1938年12月。卧室里有一堆大约30双高、已经粘连成一团的鞋子。在床头柜上，我发现了一副折叠好的眼镜，压在一个男人的钱包上。我把它们都塞进了夹克口袋。另一个房间有一个衣柜，镜框里塞着一张市政厅舞会的邀请函。上面别着一朵已经完全枯萎的玫瑰。
Kenny opened the closet door next to the dresser. And hanging there was a rotting white dress. We began to fabricate a little scene. A teenage daughter returns late from a dance with a rose. She pins it to the mirror and hangs her dress in the closet. And then something horrible happens. And that's when time stopped.
肯尼打开了衣柜门。里面挂着一件腐烂的白裙子。我们开始编造一个小场景：一个十几岁的女儿参加舞会晚归，拿着一朵玫瑰。她把它别在镜子上，把裙子挂在衣柜里。然后可怕的事情发生了。时间就在那一刻停止了。
Outside, squinting in the bright daylight, we raced back through town. Kenny and Ian were like kids coming off a roller coaster. But I had this sense of doom about the whole thing. I'd heard about the King Tut exhibit that was touring the country. I wondered if we'd be cursed, like the guys who'd found King Tut's tomb. Also, I had someone's wallet in my pocket. I took it out and showed Kenny and Ian. Inside was a bright green $1 bill, dated 1935, and a driver's license for a man named Virgil Nason.
在外面，眯着眼睛在明亮的日光下，我们冲回了镇上。肯尼和伊恩就像刚下过山车的孩子。但我对整件事有一种宿命感。我听说过正在全国巡回展出的图坦卡蒙展览。我怀疑我们会不会像那些发现图坦卡蒙陵墓的人一样受到诅咒。而且，我口袋里还有别人的钱包。我拿出来给肯尼和伊恩看。里面是一张鲜绿色的1美元钞票，日期是1935年，还有一张名为维吉尔·纳森的男人的驾照。
That night, while our dad drove us home, I put on the eyeglasses I'd found to make Kenny and Ian laugh. But then I felt bad about the joke. I didn't know anyone who died before, and now I was pretty sure I was carrying the wallet of a dead man. The next day, my brother would be going back to his high school buddies, and my best friend would be going back to our old school. I'd have to face the kids at my new school, where I hadn't made any friends, and it seemed like everyone was named Doug and played lacrosse.
那天晚上，我爸爸开车送我们回家时，我戴上发现的眼镜想逗肯尼和伊恩笑。但随后我觉得这个玩笑很糟糕。我以前没认识过什么死人，但现在我非常确定，我拿着一个死人的钱包。第二天，我哥哥又要回去找他高中的哥们儿了，我最好的朋友也要回到我们的老学校。我不得不面对新学校的孩子们，在那里我还没交到朋友，而且似乎每个人都叫道格，还打长曲棍球。
I'd always been a moody kid, but it was an unfocused sort of moodiness. Now that all this was happening in my life, my gloominess took on a new focus. I brooded about the Nason house. My homeroom teacher had been an instructor for Outward Bound. Throughout the year, he made us go solo in the woods around the school. I spent hours sitting out there, alone with my journal and a flashlight, brooding.
我一直是个情绪化的孩子，但那是一种没有焦点的忧郁。现在随着生活中发生的这些事，我的忧郁有了新的焦点。我沉溺于纳森家的事情。我的班主任曾是“外展训练”的教练。这一整年里，他让我们在学校周围的树林里独自一人活动。我花了几小时坐在那里，带着日记和手电筒，独自沉思。
The winter passed, and the only curse I suffered was grade seven. That spring, my parents went back to do their volunteer stint at the camp. This time, I brought a new friend named David. I knew it would impress him. We got up early and packed flashlights and our book bags. I think we even brought a canteen of water. It was raining as we climbed through the window of the house. Nothing looked like it had changed over the winter. And just like the first time, I had this acute feeling of being watched as we moved from room to room, touching things, opening up drawers, climbing up into the attic. David felt it, too.
冬天过去了，我受到的唯一诅咒就是七年级的功课。那个春天，父母回去做夏令营的志愿工作。这次，我带了一个新朋友叫大卫。我知道这会让他印象深刻。我们很早就起床，带上手电筒和书包。我想我们甚至带了一个水壶。当我们爬进窗户时天正下着雨。看起来并没有什么东西熬过冬天后发生了改变。就像第一次一样，当我们在房间之间移动、触摸物品、打开抽屉、爬上阁楼时，我有一种强烈的被注视感。大卫也感觉到了。
All their personal belongings were right there, so they felt so close. And I remember walking through some of these dark rooms, looking around, being afraid of perhaps uncovering something, some evil scene, or discovering that they were there, discovering that they had died there.
他们所有的私人物品都在那里，所以感觉离他们很近。我记得走过那些黑暗的房间，四处张望，害怕或许会揭开什么邪恶的现场，或者发现他们就在那里，发现他们死在了那里。
I remember thinking that we were going to find a body in a closet at any moment. I mean, I remember there were some closets and cupboards that we just flat out didn't want to open or even open up the oven. You're just afraid that you might find something that you just didn't want to see.
我记得当时想，我们随时都会在衣柜里发现一具尸体。我的意思是，我记得有些衣柜和橱柜我们根本不想打开，甚至不想打开烤箱。你就是害怕可能会看到自己不想看到的东西。
Do you remember the basement?
你还记得地下室吗？
I don't remember that. No, I don't remember the basement.
我不记得了。不，我不记得有地下室。
Did we ever go down? We did go down into the basement eventually, didn't we?
我们没去过下面吗？我们最后肯定去过地下室吧？
I still don't remember the basement. Did you go down the-- you didn't go in the basement.
我还是不记得有地下室。你下去过……你没进过地下室。
We never went into the basement. And here's why. The door to it had been blocked shot by a couch that was propped on its end, as if someone wanted to keep something down there from getting out.
我们从来没进过地下室。原因如下：通往那里的门被一个竖着靠在那里的沙发堵死了，就好像有人想阻止什么东西从下面出来一样。
I remember uncovering-- finding a small doll whose face had been burned off. And I remember being terrified of that, thinking this must have been some scene of some horrible ritual.
我记得发现了一个脸部被烧毁的小玩偶。我记得对此感到恐惧，心想这一定是某种可怕仪式留下的场景。
David has a really strong memory of a doll with its face burned off. Do you remember that?
大卫对那个脸部被烧毁的玩偶有很深刻的记忆。你记得吗？
Oh yeah. Absolutely. That was scary. The minute you mentioned it, I've got the image of it. I mean there's something so creepy about a doll that's kind of been mangled.
哦，是的，绝对记得。那很吓人。你一提起，我就有了它的画面。那种被损毁的玩偶确实有些阴森。
I remember discovering that there was these sort of smeared feces area of-- or smeared-- either it was animal or human. We couldn't figure that out.
我记得发现了一些像是粪便涂抹的区域，不知道是动物还是人的。我们没法确定。
The poop on the bed, that was scary, too. It made you wonder, what the hell is going on in here? I think at the time, we thought, oh, gee, maybe people were crashing out here. So that fit into a whole story about, oh, some fugitive on the lam from justice who's hiding out in an abandoned house, or the town alcoholic who used to crash out there after a binge, or something like that.
床上的粪便也很吓人。这让你怀疑，这里到底发生了什么鬼？我想当时我们想的是，噢，天哪，也许有人在这里过夜。所以这符合我们编的故事：某个逃避法律制裁的逃犯躲在废弃房子里，或者是镇上的酒鬼在狂欢后睡在那里，诸如此类。
The strange part is, do people just pick up and walk out the front door one day and leave letters that are incredibly personal? I mean, these were important artifacts in their family. And if they did leave for some legitimate reason-- like you move, you pack up, you move-- you don't leave things like a wallet with money in it or your address book that has the birthdays written in it of your family members. Why do you leave things like that? How could you?
奇怪的是，人们会直接起身走出前门，留下极其私人的信件吗？我的意思是，这些是他们家族的重要文物。如果他们确实因为某种正当理由离开——比如搬家，你打包离开——你不会留下钱包里的钱，或者写着家庭成员生日的记事簿。为什么要留下这些东西呢？怎么舍得？
We had a mission. The mission was to find out as much as we could about the family who had lived there. And all over the place were letters and pieces of paper. And each one was a potential clue, so we sat down in this dingy, kind of musky house. And we started to read.
我们有个使命。使命是尽可能多地找出住在这里的家庭的情况。到处都是信件和纸条。每一张都是潜在的线索，所以我们坐在这种阴暗、发霉的房子里，开始阅读。
November 29, 1933. Dear Mr. Nason, I've checked up your case quite thoroughly and find that you have already had as much, if not more, work than most people. I find also that you were working a car and a truck and that your son has a car and a truck. Also, that your team is working hauling cut lumber. So long as a man has anything at all, he has to use it, as we have to give work to the people who have nothing at all. Under these circumstances, you do not qualify for work at this time. Signed, the Office of the County Supervisor of Relief.
1933年11月29日，致纳森先生：我非常仔细地调查了您的案子，发现您已经比大多数人做了更多的工作。我还发现您拥有一辆汽车和一辆卡车，您的儿子也有一辆汽车和一辆卡车。此外，你们的团队正在从事木材运输工作。只要一个人还有任何东西，他就必须使用它，因为我们必须把工作机会留给一无所有的人。在这种情况下，您目前没有资格获得救济工作。签名：县救济监督办公室。
Dear Mama, I'm staying over tonight and go to the dance. Artie and I have had a fight. He thinks I'm going out with Eddie. I may, I don't know. I don't want him to know where I am, so don't tell him. Come over to the dance and bring my shoes, the black spike ones. Now come over, Mama, and don't be mad. Don't even tell PT. Now Mama, please don't be mad at me. Mr. Jackson is ugly today. Be sure you get Dad to come to the dance. There's a ball game tonight.
亲爱的妈妈，我今晚留宿，要去参加舞会。我和阿蒂吵架了。他认为我要和埃迪出去。我可能会去，我不知道。我不想让他知道我在哪儿，所以别告诉他。过来参加舞会，带上我的鞋子，那双黑色尖头的。现在过来吧，妈妈，别生气。甚至连PT都别告诉。妈妈，请别生我的气。杰克逊先生今天很讨厌。一定要让你爸爸来参加舞会。今晚有球赛。
Over the next two years, I returned to the Nason house four times in all. And each time, I came back with more clues about what happened. I read these letters over and over, trying to decode them, convinced that the answer about the family's downfall was hidden in some seemingly trivial comment or offhand reference. This note is written on school paper by a young girl, who was probably my age at the time.
接下来的两年里，我总共回了纳森家四次。每一次，我都带回了更多关于所发生之事的线索。我一遍又一遍地阅读这些信件，试图破译它们，确信关于这个家庭衰落的答案就隐藏在某个看似微不足道的评论或随意的提及中。这张纸条是用学校练习纸写的，出自一个和我当时年纪差不多的女孩之手。
Dear Clyde, I wanted a boyfriend, so I thought I would write to you, darling. There's no other boy around here that interests me as you do, Clyde, darling. Call me up, Clyde, darling. When I saw you last night over at Pink's, I thought I would go crazy because I love you so. From your girlfriend, ED.
亲爱的克莱德，我想找个男朋友，所以我想给你写信，亲爱的。这附近没有别的男孩像你一样让我感兴趣，克莱德，亲爱的。给我打电话吧，克莱德，亲爱的。当我昨晚在平克家看到你时，我想我会疯掉的，因为我如此爱你。来自你的女朋友，ED。
We had to take things that could help us unravel a puzzle. I mean, I don't think we even thought of it being private property at the start because it was just abandoned, and no one cared about it.
我们必须拿走那些能帮我们解开谜题的东西。我的意思是，一开始我们甚至没觉得这是私有财产，因为它是被废弃的，没人关心。
We read notes from doctors and found bills from creditors. We scanned library past due notices and studied postmarks and came up with lots of ideas about why the place had been left.
我们读了医生的笔记，发现了债权人的账单。我们浏览了图书馆的逾期通知，研究了邮戳，并对这个地方被遗弃的原因提出了很多想法。
We started to think, gee, maybe these people had their house foreclosed and were thrown out by bankers. Because it does seem as if somebody might have been shut out of the house, with all of the objects inside.
我们开始想，天哪，也许这些人被银行收回了房子，被赶了出来。因为看起来确实像是有人被拒之门外，而所有的东西都留在了里面。
One of my favorite theories was that the father died at maybe the same time the sons had to go to war. Because we're looking at papers that talk about war starting and thinking about how a couple of events with an old father and a couple of sons could very quickly finish a family.
我最喜欢的理论之一是，父亲死亡的时间可能正好赶上儿子们要去参战。因为我们看到的信件提到战争开始，心想一位老父亲和几个儿子发生的事很快就能毁掉一个家庭。
I remember finding information about bedding. I think we saw I think they were tickets or a schedule of a dog track or a horse racing track. And the story we made up was, oh, these people had lost all their money gambling.
我记得发现过关于床上用品的信息。我想我们看到的……我想那是狗场或赛马场的门票或时间表。于是我们编造的故事是，噢，这些人因为赌博输光了所有的钱。
We needed to find someone who could give us some answers, a person who knew the family or a distant relative. Freedom is a small town. Someone must have known what had happened. But when we'd go ask down at the general store or the post office, people gave us the cold shoulder. This confirmed to us that they were part of the conspiracy to bring this family down, or at least part of the cover up. In retrospect, I realized the adults may have brushed us off because we were 12 years old.
我们需要找一个能给我们答案的人，一个认识这家人的人或者远房亲戚。弗里登是一个小镇。肯定有人知道发生了什么。但当我们去杂货店或邮局询问时，人们对我们爱搭不理。这让我们确信他们是毁掉这个家庭的阴谋的一部分，或者至少是掩盖真相的一部分。事后看来，我意识到大人们之所以打发我们，是因为我们才12岁。
It was David who found the breakthrough clue-- a matchbook, matches intact, soiled but legible. It said Stop and Shop at Nason Grocery, Freedom side near Effingham Falls Bridge. We rode over and ditched our bikes under the bridge. There were two or three houses on either side, all big old Victorian buildings. But it was obvious to us which one was the Nason Grocery. There were a couple of ancient gas pumps outside and a resting Moxie soda sign. A rope held the door closed, but we were able to squeeze through.
是大卫找到了突破性的线索——一盒火柴，火柴还在里面，脏兮兮的但字迹可辨。上面写着：“停止并去纳森杂货店购物，弗里登侧，靠近埃芬汉福尔斯桥”。我们骑车过去，把自行车扔在桥下。桥的两边有两三座房子，都是巨大的维多利亚式建筑。但我们很明显知道哪一家是纳森杂货店。外面有几台古老的加油泵和一块莫克西汽水招牌。门上挂着一根绳子，但我们还是设法挤了进去。
The first thing I saw when we went through the door were the boxes of Cornflakes that lined the walls. The Nason Grocery was a completely intact, perfectly preserved store from the 1960s, with products still on the shelves. By the cash register, there were magazine racks and rows of candy. There were glass countertops displaying fishing gear and stacks of canned vegetables, corn and green beans. Some of the cans had exploded from years of heating and freezing, which we thought was cool. Upstairs, there were a few rooms that must have been an apartment.
我们进门后第一眼看到的是沿墙排列的玉米片盒子。纳森杂货店是一个完全未受破坏、保存完美的60年代商店，货架上还有产品。收银台旁边有杂志架和成排的糖果。有展示渔具的玻璃柜台和成堆的罐装蔬菜、玉米和青豆。有些罐头因为多年的加热和冷冻而爆裂，我们觉得这很酷。楼上有几个房间，一定是一个公寓。
Being in a store all of the sudden reminded us, gee, we're breaking and entering in a place that's got candy.
身处商店里突然提醒了我们，天哪，我们在一个有糖果的地方入室盗窃。
There was a small safe under the counter. And when I turned the handle, the door swung open. Inside, I found four silver dollars and three Kennedy half dollars. I also found a $5 gold coin from 1892. I took the coins.
柜台下有个小保险箱。当我转动把手时，门开了。里面有四个银元和三个肯尼迪半美元。我还发现了一枚1892年的5美元金币。我拿走了这些硬币。
I spent the eighth grade kind of detached from school. I'd stare out the window at the falling snow and think about the drifts that must've been blowing through cracks in the house. Or I'd lie awake at night and imagine how still and cold it would be in there. Instead of doing homework, I spent a lot of time reading through my box of Nason letters, drawing up a family tree from the clues we'd found.
我在八年级时对学校有一种超然的态度。我会盯着窗外的雪花发呆，想着吹进屋子缝隙里的积雪。或者我会在深夜躺着，想象那里是多么寂静和寒冷。我没有做作业，而是花大量时间阅读那一盒纳森家的信件，根据我们找到的线索绘制家谱。
Every reference to New Hampshire became relevant to the mystery. I'd sit at breakfast and stare at a tin of maple syrup and think about the Nasons. I was pretty sure that if there was some way I could support a family researching abandoned houses, that it would be my vocation in life. I was 13 years old, and I had a crush on a house.
每一个关于新罕布什尔州的提及都变得与这个谜题相关。我坐在早餐桌旁盯着一罐枫糖浆，想着纳森一家。我非常肯定，如果有什么方法能支持研究废弃房屋的家庭，那将是我的人生职业。我13岁，暗恋着一座房子。
I hadn't told my parents much about it. I was afraid they'd shut us down over fears we'd get hurt or arrested. But I remember feeling that I wanted a grown up to see it, to confirm that we hadn't imagined the whole thing. So I started to tell my mother about it. But I could see I wasn't getting it across how amazing it was. So that spring, I led my mother across the field of weeds and watched as she climbed through the window of the house.
我没怎么告诉过父母。我怕他们会因为担心我们受伤或被捕而阻止我们。但我记得我有一种感觉，我想要一个成年人看到它，确认我们不是幻想出了这一切。于是我开始告诉妈妈这件事。但我能看出她并没有体会到这有多么神奇。所以那个春天，我领着妈妈穿过荒草地，看着她爬进屋子。
I was a little appalled-- more than appalled when I went inside. It was much more-- a much greater disaster than I had imagined. Also, a much greater mystery than I had imagined. And in many ways, much more interesting for that reason.
当我进去时，我感到有些震惊，甚至是超乎震惊。它远比我想象的更加灾难，也远比我想象的更加神秘。而且正因如此，它在许多方面也更有趣。
My mom proved to be quite a sleuth. She drove me to the town cemetery, where we found plot after plot of Nason graves. There was Ivan Nason, died 1943; Bertha, died 1968; Virgil, whose dollar bill and driver's license I had, died in 1974; and Jesse, who died in 1969. There was another Jesse William who had a birthday, but there was no date of death.
我妈妈证明自己是个破案高手。她开车带我去镇上的墓地，我们在那里发现了纳森家族的一块块墓地。那里有伊凡·纳森，1943年去世；伯莎，1968年去世；维吉尔，也就是我有他那一美元钞票和驾照的那位，1974年去世；还有杰西，1969年去世。还有另一个杰西·威廉，有生日，但没有死亡日期。
So our theories of a car carrying the whole family into a ravine, of the war, of sudden plague, of the whole town rising up against the Nasons and massacring them, these no longer made sense. Whatever had driven the family from its home hadn't been sudden. The circumstances were more complicated than anything I'd imagined.
所以我们关于汽车载着全家掉进峡谷、战争、突发瘟疫、全镇人起来屠杀纳森家的理论，不再成立了。无论是什么驱使这个家庭离开家园，都不会是突发的。情况比我预想的要复杂得多。
That winter, I had my first nightmare. I was in the house rummaging through things, and the Nasons were there in the walls watching me. And they weren't friendly. The next year, I didn't go to New Hampshire. I'd started high school and was finally making friends. There was less brooding in my life. And what brooding was left had to do with girls. My mother went up on the semi-annual work weekend at the summer camp, and she brought my sister along. When they returned, they told me a story that made my blood run cold.
那个冬天，我做了第一个噩梦。我在房子里翻找东西，纳森一家就在墙里看着我。他们不友好。第二年，我没有去新罕布什尔州。我已经上了高中，终于交到了朋友。生活中的忧郁少了。剩下的忧郁也与女孩有关。妈妈在半年度的夏令营工作周末去了那里，还带上了我妹妹。当她们回来时，讲了一个让我不寒而栗的故事。
Tell me about the time that you went up with Claire. What happened?
跟我说说你和克莱尔一起去的时候。发生了什么？
That was a big mistake. I think we were both very embarrassed. We were embarrassed. We were both very embarrassed.
那是一个大错误。我想我们两个都非常尴尬。我们都很尴尬。
Yeah.
是的。
I felt I was angry.
我觉得我很生气。
You were angry?
你生气？
I was.
是的。
No, we blew it. We blew it, sort of in a sense.
不，我们搞砸了。从某种意义上说，我们搞砸了。
What happened was this. My mother had brought my sister into the house, and they'd seen a child's crib rotting away in the attic. And they decided to take it. So they drove my family's bright orange Volvo station wagon up in front and went in to get the crib.
事情是这样的。妈妈带我妹妹进了房子，她们在阁楼里看到了一个腐烂的婴儿床。她们决定把它拿走。于是她们把家里那辆亮橙色的沃尔沃旅行车开到前面，进屋去拿婴儿床。
There was no way one could bring that crib down the stairs. And finally, I found a piece of rope somewhere, tied it up, and we lowered it down the window.
根本不可能把那个婴儿床搬下楼梯。最后，我找了根绳子，把它捆好，从窗户吊了下来。
Outside the window?
窗户外面？
Yeah.
是的。
Outside the window of the house?
房子的窗户外面？
Yeah. And that's when a boy walked by and saw it. We saw him see it. We saw him see it. And we realized uh oh.
是的。就在这时，一个男孩走过看到了。我们看到他看见了。我们意识到：噢，糟糕。
The boy returned with two women, who told my mother and sister they had no right being in the house. My mom argued, asking them why, if someone somewhere had an interest in the property, they were letting it rot. The woman said it was none of her business and that she'd better leave. I felt betrayed. The scene my mother had described-- the orange car, the dangling crib, the confrontation in the middle of the road, people in Freedom had a word for greedy city folk from Massachusetts and elsewhere who came to town, plundering for antiques. They called them Massholes. That's what we'd become, and I felt sick about it. I collected all the objects and letters I'd found and put them in a small wooden fish tackle box I'd found in the Nason grocery store. I tucked the box up in our attic, and I never went in the Nason house again.
那个男孩带了两个女人回来，她们告诉我妈妈和妹妹，她们没权利待在屋子里。我妈妈据理力争，问她们既然有人关心房产，为什么让它腐烂。那个女人说这不关她的事，最好赶快离开。我感到背叛。妈妈描述的那个场景——橙色的车，悬挂的婴儿床，路中间的对抗，弗里登的人们对那些从马萨诸塞州和其他地方来镇上搜刮古董的贪婪城里人有一个词。他们叫他们“Massholes”（马萨诸塞州的混蛋）。我们就变成了那样，我对此感到恶心。我把我找到的所有物品和信件收集起来，放在我在纳森杂货店发现的一个小木制渔具盒里。我把盒子塞在阁楼里，再也没进过纳森家。
Three years later, I took a trip through New England with Ian, and we decided to take a detour to Freedom. I stopped the car where I thought the house stood. Ian remembered it being further along. So we parked and walked up and down the road. But the house was gone. All that remained was an outline of the foundation in the dirt. We drove to the bridge to see if the store was there, but it wasn't. We couldn't tell if the buildings had been torn down or if they'd burned. But they were gone, as was, I thought, any answer I'd ever get as to why they'd been left in the first place.
三年后，我和伊恩在纽英伦旅行，决定绕道去弗里登。我在我想象中房子站立的地方停下车。伊恩记得它在更远一点的地方。所以我们停车在路上走来走去。但房子不见了。剩下的只有土地上地基的轮廓。我们开车去桥边看商店还在不在，但它也没了。我们看不出建筑是被拆除了还是烧掉了。但它们消失了，我想，我关于为什么当初会被遗弃的所有答案也随之消失了。
I was having the nightmare regularly now. Each time, it was the same. I was in the Nason house or some version of it. But now undead Nasons were leaving their hiding places in the walls and attacking me. It was a terrifying dream. And I had it many times over the next 20 years.
我现在经常做那个噩梦。每一次都是一样的。我在纳森家的房子里，或者它的某个版本里。但现在，亡灵纳森一家正从墙后的藏身处出来攻击我。那是一个可怕的梦。在接下来的20年里，我做过很多次。
OK. So there's plenty in here.
好了，这盒子里有很多东西。
This summer, I went to visit my mother and looked through the box of things I'd saved from the Nason house. All the years I'd spent away from home, she'd kept the box, carefully labeled and stored through four moves.
今年夏天，我去看望妈妈，翻看了我从纳森家救出来的东西。这些年来我不在家，她一直保存着这个盒子，仔细贴上标签，经历了四次搬家都没丢。
There.
在那。
[TAPPING]
[敲击声]
Uh huh. Yeah, I remember that.
嗯。是的，我记得那个。
You see? Yes, the wooden box. You see, that's the wooden box that I remember. And I think it has things in it. It should.
你看？是的，木盒子。你看，那就是我记得的木盒子。我想里面有东西。应该有的。
The box was as I'd left it, a little makeup case with powder still inside, the eyeglasses, some children's records, and the coins, photographs of the family, the letters. And there were newspapers. Right on top was the one Ian found that very first day.
盒子和我留下它时一样，是一个带粉扑的化妆盒、眼镜、一些儿童唱片、硬币、家庭照片、信件。还有报纸。最上面就是伊恩第一天发现的那份。
Oh, and this newspaper is very old. Boston Sunday Globe, look at that. "After marching--" Jesus, [INAUDIBLE]. "After marching into the rest of Czechoslovakia in March, Hitler and Chamberlain exchanged speeches. Nazis stayed there, and Chamberlain said he mustn't do it again." [LAUGHING]
噢，这份报纸很旧了。波士顿星期日环球报，看那。 “进军……”耶稣，“在三月份进军捷克斯洛伐克的其余部分后，希特勒和张伯伦交换了演讲。纳粹留在了那里，张伯伦说他不能再这样做了。”[笑声]
April 16, 1939. And my-- yeah, my grandparents were already in exile because of this taking of Czechoslovakia. Hm.
1939年4月16日。而且我……是的，我的祖父母因为这次占领捷克斯洛伐克已经流亡了。嗯。
When my great-grandparents fled their home in Czechoslovakia, they'd left furniture, paintings, letters all very suddenly and never returned. My mother tells me that all those things probably still exist somewhere. With that in mind, she couldn't bear to see the Nason things rotting away like they had.
当我的曾祖父母逃离捷克斯洛伐克的家时，他们非常突然地留下了家具、画作、信件，再也没有回去。妈妈告诉我，所有那些东西可能现在还在某个地方存在着。考虑到这一点，她不忍心看着纳森家的东西像那样腐烂掉。
And here's a spoon. [SIGHING]
这儿还有个勺子。[叹气]
It's all very melancholy, all these little remnants.
这一切都很忧郁，所有这些小遗迹。
Why is it melancholy?
为什么忧郁？
The abandonment. The abandonment is melancholy. In a way, it's worse than throwing away, much worse. I can understand one family being obliged to flee or run, or abandon, but that nobody else cared, that it was so overwhelmingly abandoned by everybody, that nobody had cared to solve something, to resolve something. That was very offensive to me.
那种遗弃感。被遗弃是忧郁的。在某种程度上，这比扔掉更糟糕，严重得多。我可以理解一个家庭被迫逃离、放弃，但没人关心，它被所有人彻底遗弃了，没有人愿意去解决或处理它。这让我非常反感。
That was-- you know, it was like leaving a corpse. You don't leave corpses. And that's a little bit the feeling that I had, that here was a carcass, a carcass of a house, of a life, of a private-- And nobody cared to pick it up and give it a proper burial.
这……你知道，就像留下了一具尸体。你不能留下尸体。我有一种感觉，这里有一具尸骸，一具房子、一种生活、一个私密空间的尸骸。没人愿意把它捡起来好好安葬。
I thought that it was important that somebody should care, that somehow somebody was leaning over these words, reading them, unfolding these letters that somebody had bothered to write. And it really didn't matter that it was an 11-year-old boy who cared. Objects have lives. They are witness to things. And these objects were like that. So I was, in a way, glad that you were listening.
我觉得有人关心是很重要的，某种程度上有人在翻阅这些话，阅读这些信件，把某人费尽心力写的信展开。一个11岁男孩是否关心其实并不重要。物品是有生命的。它们是事物的见证。这些物品就是那样。所以，从某种程度上说，我很高兴你在倾听。
There was one letter in particular that my mother and I couldn't get out of our heads. It was different from the others. And I'd kept it separate in a plastic Ziploc bag. It was mildewed and barely legible.
有一封特别的信，我和妈妈一直忘不掉。它和其他信件不同。我把它单独放在一个塑料密封袋里。它发霉了，字迹模糊。
"April 18, 1940, Laconia Hospital. My darling, excuse writing. It's the best I can manage. They brought me to the hospital here Tuesday night at 8:30. The baby was born prematurely at 3:00 yesterday afternoon. I am writing to you-- writing for you before I name him.
“1940年4月18日，拉科尼亚医院。亲爱的，原谅我的字迹。这是我能写的最好的了。周二晚上8点半他们把我带到这里的医院。孩子在昨天下午3点早产。我写这封信……在你为他命名之前写给你。”
What are we going to do? I'm nearly crazy. Did you get my telegram? Be sure to bring the $20.50. I am weak and can't write more.
“我们要怎么办？我快疯了。你收到我的电报了吗？一定要带上20.50美元。我很虚弱，写不下去了。”
Hurry. I may die. But I love you more than ever. I registered here as your wife. I knew it would be better. With all my heart and love, come quick." Underlined, what, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
“快点。我可能会死。但我比以往任何时候都更爱你。我以你妻子的名义在这里注册了。我知道这样更好。全心全意地爱着你，快点过来。”下方划了线，1、2、3、4、5、6、7、8条横线。
I can hardly stand it. I can hardly stand it. I've thought about her so often. I've worried about her. I've worried about that kid. I've never forgotten these.
我简直无法忍受。我简直无法忍受。我经常想到她。我担心她。我担心那个孩子。我从未忘记这些。
Yeah. I remember finding that. I think you explained to me what it was about. I don't think I understood.
是的。我记得找到了那封信。我想你向我解释过它是关于什么的。我想我当时并不理解。
Yeah.
是的。
Back home in New York, I started doing research on the internet, working off the list of Nason names I'd found in the cemetery. Eventually I found this posting in a genealogy website. "Nasons of Freedom, New Hampshire, looking for relatives of Jesse Nason and his wife Bertha. Any info from their kids or grandkids and pictures would be awesome. They are my great-great-grandparents."
回到纽约家中，我开始在互联网上做研究，根据我在墓地找到的纳森姓氏名单进行工作。最终我在一个家谱网站上找到了这篇帖子：“新罕布什尔州弗里登的纳森家族，寻找杰西·纳森和他妻子伯莎的亲戚。任何关于他们子女或孙辈的信息和照片都将不胜感激。他们是我的曾曾祖父母。”
The person who'd written it is named Samantha Thurston. I sent her an email confessing everything. And this is what she wrote back.
写下这篇帖子的人叫萨曼莎·瑟斯顿。我给她发了一封电子邮件，坦白了一切。这就是她回复的内容。
"Hello, Adam. I'm very interested in what you found and almost wish you had taken all that you found. Jesse and Bertha are my great-great-grandparents. I don't know a lot about them, but they did have a store in Freedom, New Hampshire and were well known.
“你好，亚当。我对你发现的东西非常感兴趣，几乎希望你拿走了所有你发现的东西。杰西和伯莎是我的曾曾祖父母。我不太了解他们，但他们在弗里登开过一家店，很有名。”
We exchanged a few more emails and made plans to meet. Samantha said the immediate family either didn't have many answers or didn't want to talk. Her last email to me included this cryptic postscript about the Nasons. "They might not be what you'd expect. They are a rough crowd." The line is followed with three exclamation points.
我们又交换了几封邮件，并计划见面。萨曼莎说，直系亲属要么没有多少答案，要么不想谈论这件事。她发给我的最后一封邮件里有一句关于纳森一家的神秘附言：“他们可能不是你预期的那样。他们是一群粗野的人。”这句话后面跟着三个感叹号。
Coming up, one of the rough crowd meets one of those meddling kids, in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
稍后，粗野人群中的一员将与一个爱管闲事的孩子见面，稍后继续回到我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We're devoting our entire show today to just one story, a real life mystery, "The House Near Loon Lake." We first broadcast today's show in 2001. Adam Beckman resumes his tale.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天全场节目致力于讲述一个故事，一个现实生活中的悬疑案，《卢恩湖畔的房子》。我们首次播出今天这期节目是在2001年。亚当·贝克曼继续讲述他的故事。
In August, I drive north to New Hampshire to meet with Samantha Thurston, the woman from the internet, and see if I can find someone to talk to me about the Nasons. I've brought the box of Nason stuff with me. It's small, about a foot square. Inside are family letters, the coins I took from the grocery store, the can of Hershey's syrup from the Nason's kitchen. I'm hoping to give it to someone who cares about the stuff. If not, I plan to bury it on the spot where the house stood.
八月，我开车向北去新罕布什尔州见萨曼莎·瑟斯顿，那个我在互联网上找到的女人，看看能不能找到人跟我聊聊纳森一家。我随身带着那盒纳森家的东西。它很小，大约一平方英尺。里面有家书、我从杂货店拿走的硬币、从纳森家厨房拿的好时糖浆罐。我希望能把它交给在乎这些东西的人。如果没人要，我打算把它埋在房子原来站立的地方。
At the turnoff from Route 25, I take a short bypass called Nason Road. On the way into town, I stopped to get directions from a woman working in her front yard. She's wearing a sweatshirt that says Nason Landscaping.
在25号公路的转弯处，我走了一条叫纳森路的小路。去镇上的路上，我停下来向一位在院子里工作的女士问路。她穿着一件写着“纳森园艺”的卫衣。
Samantha had told me that the Nasons either didn't know what had happened to the house or didn't want to talk. She also said that everyone would know I was in town. It's hard not to feel a little paranoid. Here I am, an outsider from New York City, come to town with details about the past, digging around for more details. I'm apprehensive about what kind of reception I'll get.
萨曼莎告诉过我，纳森一家要么不知道房子发生了什么，要么不想谈。她还说全镇都会知道我来了。很难不感到有点多疑。我是一个来自纽约城的局外人，带着关于过去的细节来到镇上，挖掘更多的细节。我对会得到什么样的接待感到忐忑。
I arrive in Freedom August 2 and a parade is marching through the center of town. It's Old Home Week, the annual homecoming festival, an event created by the governor to combat problems of abandoned homes and farms in New Hampshire, all the way back in 1898. After the Civil War, young people had left the state in droves for better land and opportunities they'd noticed elsewhere.
8月2日我到达弗里登，一场游行队伍正穿过市中心。这是“老家周”，一年一度的返乡节，一个早在1898年就由州长设立的活动，目的是解决新罕布什尔州废弃房屋和农场的问题。南北战争后，年轻人成群结队地离开该州，去别处寻找更好的土地和机会。
I'd last visited in the 1970s. And a few things have changed since. The town's only store has been replaced with a shop for tourists selling tea doilies, hand-dipped candles, and Beanie Babies. Farming is pretty much dead. And city people have moved in because they love how charming it is. The place is so self-consciously quaint that you feel like you're on a movie set about a small town, tidy with just enough dilapidation around the edges to be rustic.
我上次访问是在70年代。从那以后发生了些变化。镇上唯一的商店被一家卖蕾丝垫、手工浸蜡烛和豆豆娃的游客商店取代了。农业基本上死光了。城里人因为喜欢这里多么迷人而搬了进来。这个地方非常刻意地古雅，让你感觉就像身处一部关于小镇的电影布景中，整洁但边缘处有足够的破败感，以显出乡村气息。
The parade moves past the old town hall, the one shop across the town's only intersection to the cemetery, then turns around for another pass. The theme for the parade this year is We Are Freedom. When I marched in the parade as a kid, the theme was Freedom of the Press. I dressed as a radio reporter and pretended to interview the spectators, an irony so bizarre I don't really know what else to say about it.
游行队伍经过旧市政厅，那是镇上唯一的十字路口，穿过那家商店到墓地，然后折返。今年游行的主题是“我们是自由”。当我小时候参加游行时，主题是“新闻自由”。我打扮成电台记者，假装采访观众，这真是极其讽刺，以至于我不知道该说什么。
[CLOCK CHIMING]
[时钟报时声]
That afternoon, I check into the only place to stay in town, a bed and breakfast called the Freedom House. I'd been concerned that some distant relative of the Nasons might own it, part of the rough crowd. I shouldn't have worried. The owner's a New Yorker. There's Princess Di memorabilia in the library. And my room's painted bright pink.
那天下午，我入住镇上唯一的住宿点，一家叫“自由之家”的民宿。我曾担心纳森家的某个远房亲戚可能会拥有它，属于那个“粗野人群”。我真多虑了。老板是纽约人。图书馆里有戴安娜王妃的纪念品，我的房间被漆成亮粉色。
In fact, it's been called the Ooh La La Room. I've had some people from Paris here, came in and said, ooh, la, la. But anyway.
事实上，它被称为“哦啦啦房”。有一些来自巴黎的客人住过这里，进来就说“噢，啦，啦”。但不管怎样。
Patrick Nealy is part of the new breed in Freedom. In the five years he's lived here, he's had the B&B meticulously restored. Antique toiletries and bottles of talcum powder line the shelves of the washroom. On a hallway table, silk gloves rest on top of a purse next to a pair of opera glasses. His things are just like the stuff in my box of Nason knickknacks, only better quality.
帕特里克·尼利是弗里登的新一代。他住在这里的五年里，将民宿修复得一丝不苟。古董洗漱用品和爽身粉瓶摆满了盥洗室的架子。在走廊的桌子上，丝绸手套放在钱包上面，旁边是一副歌剧望远镜。他的东西就像我那一盒纳森家的小饰品，只是质量更好。
Standing there with a dirty little wooden box under my arm, I feel sort of pathetic. And when Patrick starts talking about how people can create instant ancestors out of old junk, it doesn't make me feel any better.
胳膊下夹着那个破旧的小木盒站在那里，我感到自己很可怜。当帕特里克开始谈论人们如何从旧垃圾中创造“即时祖先”时，这并没让我感觉好受些。
I've pieced together histories through photos. We've come up with photographs. I have a number of instant ancestors in this house that I've kind of-- to create the ambiance. And in a few instances, I've tried to trace whatever I could about them.
我通过照片拼凑过历史。我们找到过照片。我在这所房子里有几个“即时祖先”，为了营造氛围。在一些案例中，我试过尽可能追溯关于他们的一切。
Patrick's learned a lot about the history of the town. So I ask him about the Nason house. He doesn't know anything about it, but he does say that a Nason cousin named Rachel Mulvy once owned this very building and that she lived here, and died here.
帕特里克对镇上的历史了解很多。所以我问他关于纳森房子的事。他对此一无所知，但他确实说一个叫瑞秋·穆尔维的纳森家族表亲曾经拥有过这栋建筑，她住在这里，也死在这里。
I think that Rachel's still in the house. I've had a few guests tell me they've heard someone walking on the second floor. So I don't know that you'll hear it, but I mean, I've heard people down at the end rooms-- I usually don't tell them, but she was a little old lady. So you might hear little slippered feet. And we've had a few things with lights, light bulbs suddenly breaking.
我觉得瑞秋还在房子里。有几位客人告诉我，他们听到有人在二楼走路。我不知道你会不会听到，但我是听过楼下尽头房间的声音——我通常不告诉他们，但她是个老太太。所以你可能会听到拖鞋声。我们也出过几次事，灯泡突然破碎。
I have a couple of days to kill before my meeting with Samantha. And at breakfast, Patrick suggests I talk to a few locals who might have known the Nason family. The first one on his list lives right across the street.
在我和萨曼莎见面之前我有两天时间。早餐时，帕特里克建议我找几个可能认识纳森一家的当地人聊聊。名单上的第一个人就住在街对面。
Well, my name is Gail Holmgren Bickford. I came here at the age of six months with my parents and have spent most of my summers here. What else would you like to know?
嗯，我叫盖尔·霍姆格伦·比克福德。我六个月大时就随父母来到这里，大部分夏天都是在这里度过的。你还想知道什么？
Do you remember-- do you remember the Nason family?
你记得……你记得纳森一家吗？
Of course. They were scruffy little kids. They were always kind of disheveled and half-dressed, and needing to be washed. They were real-- what do you call it, from the-- the ones who went across on the covered wagons and never got to school?
当然。他们是那种邋里邋遢的小孩。总是衣衫不整，半穿半脱，需要洗澡。他们是那种……你怎么说呢，那些坐着篷车穿过，从来没去过学校的孩子？
Really?
真的吗？
Well, I guess maybe they did go to school, but I think they went barefoot. They were sort of scary to go by there. If we walked to the beach, you went pretty fast to get by that house.
嗯，我猜他们也许确实去过学校，但我认为他们是赤脚去的。走过那里有点吓人。如果我们步行去海滩，经过那座房子时你会走得很快。
Why?
为什么？
I don't know exactly. I think the firemen burned it down for a practice session.
我不清楚。我想消防员是为了练习引火把它烧了。
What was their status in the town? Were they ostracized?
他们在镇上的地位如何？是被排斥了吗？
I don't know. I don't know anything about that. And I don't know the whole family setup, but one of them was into race horses and made quite a lot of money, I think, in race horsing.
我不知道。我对那件事一无所知。我也搞不懂整个家庭的结构，但他们中有一个人热衷于赛马，我想他在赛马中赚了很多钱。
I asked Gail if she thinks financial hardship brought the family down, but she can't confirm anything.
我问盖尔是否认为经济困难导致了家庭衰落，但她证实不了任何事。
About 1940-something, they build a bypass so that the main Route 25 did not go through town anymore. And then the town began to die out. There was no reason to come to town. And then the stores lost business. And they began to close up one by one. I have no idea whether that's what hit that family, but there may be somebody around who knows.
大约1940年左右，他们修建了一条支路，这样25号主干道就不再经过镇上了。然后镇子就开始衰落了。没有理由再来这个镇上。商店生意惨淡。它们开始一家接一家地关闭。我不知道是不是这就是打击那个家庭的原因，但可能周围还有人知道。
Nason, sure. Brought up with them.
纳森，当然。跟他们一起长大的。
Carol Chase was the fire chief in Freedom about the time the house was burned. I find him sitting on his porch on a road outside of town. He's 92 years old and hard of hearing, but he does remember the fire.
卡罗尔·蔡斯在房子被烧毁时是弗里登的消防队长。我发现他坐在镇外一条路上的门廊里。他92岁了，听力不好，但他确实记得那场火。
We just lit it with a match, newspaper and a match.
我们只是用火柴点燃了它，报纸和火柴。
Was the house empty, or was it full of stuff?
房子是空的，还是塞满了东西？
Nobody lived there.
没人住在那。
Why did you start a fire?
为什么要放火？
Why?
为什么？
Yeah.
是的。
Well, they wanted it burned.
嗯，他们想把它烧掉。
Who wanted it burned?
谁想烧掉它？
The people who owned it. That's about all I know about Freedom. People mind their own business.
房主。这就是我知道的关于弗里登的一切。人们各管各的事。
He looks away from me as he says this, and I take the hint. Later that day, I learned he's related to the Nasons by marriage. In fact, he Samantha's grandfather. I spend some time worrying over why he never mentioned this.
他说这话时避开了我的目光，我听出了弦外之音。那天晚些时候，我得知他通过婚姻与纳森家有亲戚关系。事实上，他是萨曼莎的祖父。我花了些时间纠结他为什么从未提过这件事。
[GLASS CLINKING]
[玻璃碰撞声]
That afternoon, I go to a junk shop on the outskirts of town, discarded appliances, clothing, and a surprising number of old family photos. The owner, John Woodard, salvages most of this stuff from traumatic moments in people's lives, a divorce or a death, or when they move from a house to a retirement home. As it turns out, back in the mid '70s he got a call about the Nason house.
那天下午，我去了镇郊的一家杂货店，那里有废弃的电器、衣服和数量惊人的旧家庭照片。店主约翰·伍达德从人们生活中创伤的时刻回收了大部分东西，比如离婚、死亡，或者当他们搬进养老院时。结果证明，在70年代中期，他接到过一个关于纳森房子的电话。
They were getting ready to knock down that house. And a guy called me up. And he said, gee, you ought to come over. He said, there's boxes and boxes of old whiskey bottles with paper labels and all this stuff in there. I got 10 or 12 boxes. I've sold them over the years.
他们准备推倒那座房子。一个家伙给我打了电话。他说：“嘿，你得过来。那里有成箱成箱带有纸标签的旧威士忌瓶子和各种东西。”我拿了10或12箱。这些年来我把它们卖掉了。
Do you remember if there's anything in here that you got from the house, the Nason house?
你记得这儿有没有什么东西是你从那房子拿的，那个纳森家的房子？
If I still got some that have labels. One more spot. Let's check down here.
如果我还剩下一些有标签的。再看一个地方。我们看看这边。
John walks me out past aisles of discarded family possessions to a barn filled with hundreds of bottles.
约翰领着我穿过堆满废弃家庭物品的过道，来到一个装满数百个瓶子的谷仓。
Yeah, see, something like this. Pickwick Ale bottle, probably from about 1920, in the '20s.
是的，你看，像这样。皮克威克啤酒瓶，大概是1920年代的。
I'd taken a Pickwick Ale bottle opener from the Nason house and used it all through college. It was the one relic I'd kept for myself when I packed up the Nason stuff.
我从纳森家拿了一个皮克威克啤酒瓶开瓶器，大学时一直用着它。那是我收拾纳森东西时唯一留给自己的遗物。
Do you remember where in the house you found that?
你记得在房子哪里发现它的吗？
These were upstairs. They were upstairs in some boxes. Of course, the roof had fallen in on part of it, if you remember. And the upstairs was-- it was one of those you said, is it really worth taking a chance getting those boxes down from upstairs? But we did.
这些是在楼上。它们在楼上的一些盒子里。当然，如果你还记得的话，屋顶的一部分已经塌进去了。楼上是……那是那种你会问“冒险把这些盒子从楼上搬下来真的值得吗”的地方。但我们还是搬了。
John hands it to me. It's got the same veneer of rust on it that everything in the Nason house had.
约翰把它递给我。上面有着和纳森房子里所有东西一样的一层锈迹。
This is $5.
这是5美元。
He gives it to me for free, for my project, he says.
他说为了我的项目，免费给我。
I'm supposed to meet Samantha, my internet Nason contact, at the B&B at 1 o'clock. And she shows up 15 minutes early. A red pickup truck tears into the lot in a cloud of dust, and a tough looking woman in a flower print dress gets out and slams the door. Samantha's young, in her 20s. She's made up, hair tied back in a bow, but her demeanor is all tomboy.
我本应该在1点钟在民宿见萨曼莎，那个我在网上联系到的纳森后人。她提前15分钟到了。一辆红色皮卡车卷着尘土冲进停车场，一个穿着花裙子、看起来很强悍的女人走下来，“砰”地关上了门。萨曼莎很年轻，20多岁。她化着妆，头发扎成蝴蝶结，但举止十足像个假小子。
Well, I talked to the family yesterday, to actually Allen Nason. He's the one that I'm closest to out of the whole family.
嗯，我昨天跟家里人谈过了，实际上是艾伦·纳森。在整个家族中，他是跟我关系最亲近的。
We talk, and it's like we've been living in parallel worlds. Samantha's been looking for clues about the family's history for 10 years. She tells me she's been scouring graveyards and reading through public records, trying to construct a family tree. She began her search when she heard rumors that she had Native American ancestry. She decided to find out if she did to get financial aid for college. Before long, she'd figured out her grandfather was, in fact, an illegitimate child of Ernest Nason, one of Bertha and Jesse's kids, although her grandfather was not the person in that letter my mom had remembered all these years.
我们交谈着，就像生活在平行的世界里。萨曼莎10年来一直在寻找家族历史的线索。她告诉我她一直在搜寻墓地并翻阅公共记录，试图构建家谱。当她听到关于自己有美洲原住民血统的传闻时，她开始了搜寻。她决定弄清楚自己是否有血统以获得大学资助。不久，她就搞清楚了她的祖父实际上是欧内斯特·纳森的私生子，他是伯莎和杰西的孩子之一，尽管她的祖父并不是我妈妈多年来一直记得的那封信里的人。
And they have a lot of hard feelings in the family as it is.
而且家里人现在的感觉非常复杂。
Samantha's family, hearing what she was uncovering, wasn't too keen on her research project and didn't cooperate.
萨曼莎的家人听到她在发掘这些东西，并不是很感兴趣，也没有配合。
It was like, go to hell away. I don't want to talk to you about this. It's none of your business. Well, it is. It's my heritage. It's my history.
他们就像是说：“滚开。我不想跟你谈这个。这不关你的事。”好吧，它就是关我的事。这是我的遗产。这是我的历史。
I left my box of stuff from the Nason house upstairs in the Ooh, La, La Room. I wanted to give it to someone in the family, but I wanted to be sure it would go to someone who'd care. As we talk, it becomes clear to me how much it would mean to Samantha. So I bring it down and put it on the floor in front of her.
我把我从纳森家带出来的东西盒子留在了楼上的“哦啦啦房”。我想把它交给家里的人，但我想确保它能给一个在乎的人。交谈时，我很清楚这对萨曼莎意味着什么。所以我把它拿下来，放在她面前的地板上。
Wow. How do I get this open?
哇。我怎么打开它？
It opens on the-- like that.
打开方式是……像这样。
Oh, neat. Oh my goodness. You even got papers. Oh, wow.
噢，整洁。噢，天哪。你甚至还有信纸。噢，哇。
Yeah, that was probably one of the first things we found when we went in the house.
是的，那可能是我们进屋子时找到的第一批东西之一。
Oh my goodness. Ain't that neat? I can't believe this. This is unbelievable. You have no idea what you've done.
噢，天哪。这不是很整洁吗？我简直不敢相信。这太不可思议了。你根本不知道你做了什么。
She opens an envelope with her great-great-grandmother's name handwritten on it. She handles it incredibly gently. I watch as she lets the contents fall into her hands. It's a bunch of tiny recipes cut out from a newspaper.
她打开了一个信封，上面手写着她曾曾祖母的名字。她动作极其轻柔地处理着。我看着她让里面的内容落入手中。是一叠从报纸上剪下来的小菜谱。
Oh my god. And you know what? I never even knew them. Oh, my. That's so cool. Oh, my goodness. I hope they appreciate it as much. I really do.
噢，天哪。你知道吗？我甚至从来没见过他们。噢，天。这太酷了。噢，天哪。我希望他们像你一样珍惜它。我真心希望。
It's actually a blessing that you had gone into that house during that time period. Because once it fell in, everything was scooped up, thrown in a dump truck, and taken to the dump. And all the memories, everything that they left behind that should have been divvied up so that it could've been passed down, was all lost. So it actually was a good thing that you were a nosy little boy. [LAUGHING]
实际上，你在那个时期进入那所房子真是一种祝福。因为一旦它倒塌，所有东西都会被铲起来，扔进翻斗车，带到垃圾场。所有的回忆，所有他们留下的、本应分配给后代的东西，全都丢失了。所以，你当个爱管闲事的小男孩其实是件好事。[笑声]
Samantha didn't know much about why the Nason house had been abandoned, but she told me a man named David Buzzwell, who lives across the street from where it once stood, might have some answers. On the way up to his house, I noticed a sign. "Trespassers will be shot. Survivors will be shot twice." David's sitting on his front porch with his friend Mabel Davis.
萨曼莎对纳森房子为什么会被废弃了解不多，但她告诉我，住在那栋房子遗址对面的大卫·巴兹威尔可能有一些答案。在去他家的路上，我注意到一个牌子。“入侵者将被枪杀。幸存者将被补枪。”大卫正和他的朋友梅布尔·戴维斯坐在前门廊上。
How does it happen you want to know about the Nasons?
你怎么会想知道纳森家的事？
When I was a little boy, when I was about 11 years old, I was in a summer camp here. Once we get talking, I realized the trespassing sign is David's idea of a joke. It's Sunday afternoon, and they're drinking Mudslides. Do you remember that house?
当我是个小男孩时，大概11岁，我曾在那里的夏令营待过。我们开始交谈后，我意识到那个入侵者标志是大卫的恶作剧。那是周日下午，他们正在喝泥石流鸡尾酒。你记得那座房子吗？
Of course I do, honey. Been in it many times.
当然记得，亲爱的。进过好多次。
Oh, really? When the Nasons were living there?
噢，真的吗？是在纳森一家住在那儿的时候？
Yeah, Mr. and Mrs. Nason were living there. And I can see Mrs. Nason now taking out a can of biscuits. Honest to god, I bet that pan was that big.
是的，纳森先生和太太住在那儿。我现在还能看到纳森太太拿出一罐饼干。说真的，我敢打赌那个烤盘有那么大。
Mabel's arms are spread wide as she says this. The image is pure Norman Rockwell. And frankly, it's a relief.
梅布尔说这话时双臂张开。这个画面完全是诺曼·洛克威尔风格的。老实说，这让我松了口气。
And what were the Nasons like?
纳森一家人怎么样？
Well, they were wonderful people, really. How would you say about Jess? All of his kids worked and worked hard.
嗯，他们是很棒的人，真的。你觉得杰斯怎么样？他的所有孩子都工作，而且工作得很努力。
Both Mabel and David knew the Nasons and had been in their house. But David, like me, had only been inside after it was abandoned.
梅布尔和大卫都认识纳森一家，也去过他们家。但大卫和我一样，只在它被废弃后进去过。
Oh, it was full of treasures, old parlor sets, Morris chairs, advertising cans. The place was just packed with stuff like that. They were pack rats, anyway. They collected everything, everything.
噢，里面全是宝藏，旧客厅家具、莫里斯椅、广告罐。地方装满了那样的东西。无论如何，他们都是囤积狂。他们收藏一切，一切。
Why would they just-- why would they just leave all that?
为什么他们会……为什么他们会留下所有那些东西？
Don't ask me. Just the way they were.
别问我。他们就是那样。
I would think the grandkids would want to--
我以为孙辈们会想要……
Didn't worry about it.
没人在乎。
Didn't care about her?
没人关心她？
No, none of them.
不，他们都没人关心。
Why not?
为什么不？
You know young people are. They don't care about old things today.
你知道现在的年轻人是什么样。他们现在不在乎旧东西。
Dave and Mabel tell me that Bertha died in 1968 and Jesse soon after in '69. And then things fell apart in the Nason family.
戴夫和梅布尔告诉我，伯莎死于1968年，杰西在1969年不久后去世。然后纳森家族就分崩离析了。
When Jess died, one of the children was in charge.
当杰斯去世时，孩子们中的一个负责。
He was made the executor.
他被任命为执行人。
He was the executor, yes, of the estate. And there were some that were very, very put out.
他是执行人，是的，负责遗产。有些人感到非常、非常不爽。
They had to sign off and give him the authority to dispose of it. And some of them were not doing.
他们必须签字并赋予他处理房产的权力。有些人没签。
And some would not do it.
有些人就是不签。
No. That is correct. It's a terrible thing to say, but as they died off one by one by one it made it easier, but it wasn't even settled when this person who was in charge settled the estate. He had died, and still it was left.
不。是这样的。说出来很可怕，但随着他们一个接一个去世，事情变得容易了，但当这个负责人处理遗产时，它甚至还没定下来。他去世了，但事情还留在那。
And then the widow was paying the taxes all these years. And she said, well, I'm not going to continue to pay them. Let them go. I mean, I think there were one or two of the family left. And they didn't want to pay them.
然后那个寡妇这些年来一直替他们交税。她说，好吧，我不会再付了。随它去吧。我的意思是，我想家里只剩下一两个了。他们不想付。
No.
不。
So she said, to heck with it. I'm not going to. So the town took it for taxes.
所以她说，见鬼去吧。我不付了。所以镇上把它收回去抵税了。
I finally went to the town. And I said, that's a fire hazard. I built a new house here. People over there are poring around. I said they could step on a nail, a glass, a wire, and sue. It's not posted. So I said it ought to be burned.
我最终去了镇上。我说，那是火灾隐患。我在这里建了新房子。人们在那边到处转悠。我说他们可能会踩到钉子、玻璃、电线，然后起诉。没贴告示。所以我说它应该被烧掉。
I was at my daughter's. And I was in her kitchen the day they were burning that. We could see the flames and everything.
我在女儿家。他们烧那房子的那天我正在她的厨房里。我们可以看到火焰和所有东西。
Oh, yeah, I remembered. I remember the fire department coming and burning it.
噢，是的，我记得。我记得消防部门来烧它。
Yeah.
是的。
I had communicated with Mr. Thompson. He said to me at the time, will you arrange with the fire department to burn it at a practice session? And I will give them $1,000 donation, which he did. And I said, thank god, because it was an eyesore. And people were in and out of it all the time.
我曾与汤普森先生沟通过。当时他对我说，你能不能安排消防队把它作为练习烧了？我会捐1000美元，他也确实捐了。我说，谢天谢地，因为那是个眼中钉。人们一直进进出出的。
Was it still full of stuff when it burned?
它烧的时候里面还装满东西吗？
There was a lot of junk in there, yeah.
里面有很多垃圾，是的。
Now the Nasons also had a store in Effingham Falls. There was an old--
纳森一家在埃芬汉福尔斯还有一家店。那里有个旧的……
Oh, yes, they certainly did. Jess and Bertha had the store right--
噢，是的，他们当然有。杰斯和伯莎就在那儿有店……
It wasn't Effingham Falls.
不是埃芬汉福尔斯。
No, it was still Freedom.
不，那还是在弗里登。
Freedom.
弗里登。
What do you remember about the store?
关于那个商店你还记得什么？
Well, I know it did quite a business. It sold a lot of beer.
嗯，我知道它生意很好。卖了很多啤酒。
And they had candy.
他们还有糖果。
Oh, yes.
噢，是的。
There was a glass showcase.
有一个玻璃展示柜。
And they had groceries. They had groceries.
他们有杂货。他们有杂货。
And that store was just packed with everything. You could hardly get through.
而且那家店真是塞满了东西。你几乎没法通过。
Well, that's how Jess was.
嗯，杰斯就是那样。
Yeah.
是的。
Jess was like that, he just had a lot of stuff?
杰斯是那样，他只是有很多东西？
Well, he was a keeper of everything.
嗯，他是一个什么都留着的人。
Do you remember when it closed or why?
你还记得它是什么时候关闭的，或者为什么吗？
They both died. And none of the kids wanted to run it.
他们都死了。而且没有孩子想经营它。
Why would a family leave all their things, these precious things, not of value, but of great emotional value?
为什么一个家庭会留下所有的东西，这些珍贵的、不是因为金钱价值，而是因为巨大的情感价值的东西？
No, no, but a sentimental value.
不，不，是一种感伤的价值。
Yeah.
是的。
I've never really thought of it, but it seems rather tragic in a way. I mean, that was a large family. I mean, how well do you know people? How many of them were interested in knowing?
我从来没真正想过，但这在某种程度上相当悲剧。我的意思是，那是一个大家庭。我的意思是，你有多了解他们？他们中有多少人有兴趣去了解？
And so the house and the store were abandoned because the kids didn't care. In some ways, this was bleaker than anything I'd imagined back when I was 11. I'd assumed a murder, or an illness, or an accident caused the Nasons to leave all these things behind, something out of the family's control. But in fact, it was the opposite. The family made it happen. They didn't care about the stuff, or they just didn't care to remember.
所以房子和商店被废弃是因为孩子们不在乎。在某些方面，这比我11岁时想象的任何事情都要凄凉。我以为是谋杀、疾病或意外导致纳森一家留下了所有这些东西，一些超出家庭控制范围的事情。但事实上，情况恰恰相反。是家庭造成了这一切。他们不在乎这些东西，或者他们就是不想记住。
Too bad they weren't here to tell you. They were characters, weren't they?
可惜他们不在了，不能告诉你。他们很有个性，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Nice people, but they were a breed that's hard to find.
好人，但他们是一个很难找到的品种。
Well, they were the old school, David.
嗯，他们是老派的，大卫。
Yeah, that's right. They made everything do.
是的，没错。他们什么都凑合用。
Yeah. But didn't everybody then? Those were the good old days--
是的。但那时候不每个人都这样吗？那是美好的旧时光……
Yeah, no kidding.
是的，不开玩笑了。
--when we had everything but money.
……那时候我们拥有除了钱以外的一切。
Yes, I guess so.
是的，我想是吧。
You better believe you did.
你最好相信你有。
I had a swimming pool and a Mercedes.
我有一个游泳池和一辆奔驰。
Well, of course you would, and a place for a pony.
嗯，当然，还有养小马的地方。
Members of the Nason family who declined to be interviewed on tape confirmed the story Mabel and Dave told me. Jesse and Bertha Nason lived in the house until 1946. That's when they opened a store near Effingham Falls and moved to the apartment above the store. They took what they needed and left the rest in the old house, using it as storage and keeping open the possibility that they'd move back someday.
拒绝接受采访的纳森家族成员证实了梅布尔和戴夫告诉我的故事。杰西和伯莎·纳森住在房子里直到1946年。那时他们在埃芬汉福尔斯附近开了家店，搬到了店上面的公寓里。他们带走了需要的东西，留下了剩下的在旧房子里，把它当成仓库，并保留了将来有一天搬回来的可能性。
When Jesse and Bertha died, the fight over the estate began. Immediately their kids-- there were nine of them-- locked up the store until it could be resolved. The house stayed pretty much as it was.
当杰西和伯莎去世后，遗产之争就开始了。他们的九个孩子立即锁上了商店，直到问题得到解决。房子基本上保持了原样。
After 11 years, the fight was settled. The property was auctioned, the money was split, and the buildings were razed to the ground. I asked an elder Nason why they didn't clear out the precious things in the house. And she said, what precious things? It was full of crap. And I mean crap.
11年后，纠纷解决了。房产被拍卖，钱被分了，建筑物被夷为平地。我问一位纳森家的长辈为什么他们不清理房子里的那些珍贵的东西。她说：“什么珍贵的东西？里面全是垃圾。我的意思是垃圾。”
As for the woman in the letter that my mother was never able to forget, no one knew anything about her or her baby. David and Mabel told me this just figures in a little town like Freedom.
至于信中妈妈一直无法忘记的那个女人，没人知道关于她或她孩子的任何事。大卫和梅布尔告诉我，在弗里登这种小镇，这就是常态。
Are you kidding, honey?
你在开玩笑吗，亲爱的？
It's a "Peyton Place."
这就像《佩顿之家》。
Explain that. What do you mean?
解释一下。你什么意思？
It's just like every other town.
这就像其他所有镇子一样。
Yeah. There's nothing different. There are all of these little--
是的。没什么不同。有所有这些小……
No.
不。
--skeletons in the closet and bedroom affairs. Yeah.
……壁橱里的秘密和卧室里的风流韵事。是的。
Things would happen like in any typical, old town. Right?
事情发生在任何典型的老镇子都一样，对吧？
Yeah. It's all by gossip.
是的。全靠流言。
It's all--
它全……
Yeah.
是的。
In retrospect, I know it was a little much, my obsession with the Nasons as a kid. I found this stuff in their house precious, so I assumed they would too. But of course, the relics in their house weren't about my life. They carried no memories, good or bad. It's possible that for the Nasons, they were reminders of an inheritance dispute or other disputes that they'd just as soon forget.
事后看来，我知道我小时候对纳森一家的痴迷有点过头了。我觉得在他们房子里找到的东西很珍贵，所以我想他们也会这么觉得。但当然，他们房子里的遗迹与我的生活无关。它们不承载回忆，无论好坏。可能对于纳森一家来说，它们是关于继承纠纷或其他纠纷的提醒，他们宁愿忘记。
When I was talking to my friend David about the Nason house, he told me this story. His wife's father had recently and suddenly died and left behind a house that no one in the family wants. So David and his wife, Susan, now find themselves involved in figuring out what to do with it.
当我和朋友大卫谈论纳森房子时，他告诉我这个故事。他妻子的父亲最近突然去世，留下一座家里没人想要的房子。所以大卫和他的妻子苏珊现在发现自己正忙于处理它。
I feel like it's on the cusp of being abandoned. No one's living there. It's ripe for being vandalized. And what do you do with a house like that?
我觉得它处于被废弃的边缘。没人住在里面。它很容易被破坏。你拿这样的房子怎么办？
And now, it's strange. I mean, it's tied up in this weird world of legal probate where you can't really do anything with the property. You just kind of have to maintain it until some future court date. The property's become a ball and chain.
现在这很奇怪。我的意思是，它被束缚在法律遗嘱认证这个奇怪的世界里，你对财产什么也做不了。你只能维护它，直到未来的某个法庭日期。这房子变成了一个枷锁。
And Susan said an interesting thing, was, gosh, I wish that house would just burn down. And I thinking, gosh, well, why would you wish the house to be burned down? It's partly-- there's a lot of memories tied up in the house and emotions tied up between her and her dad, symbolized by the house. But something about it seemed relevant.
苏珊说了一件有趣的事，是“天哪，我希望那房子直接烧掉”。我想，天哪，你为什么希望房子烧掉？部分原因是房子里联系着很多回忆，还有她和她父亲之间的情感，由房子象征着。但关于它的一些事情似乎很有相关性。
I wanted to show Samantha the spot where the house had once stood. So in the early evening, we walked through town and onto Loon Lake Road. We crashed through the bushes for a while, hoping that we could find the old foundation or something. But there wasn't a trace. In fact, the very land where I remember the house was gone. The soil had been hauled away weeks before by bulldozers constructing part of the new Freedom Elementary School.
我想带萨曼莎去看看房子曾经站立的地方。所以傍晚时分，我们穿过镇子，走到卢恩湖路。我们在灌木丛中乱冲了一阵，希望找到旧地基什么的。但一点痕迹都没有。事实上，我记得房子所在的土地都不见了。几个星期前，推土机在建设新弗里登小学时已经把土壤运走了。
Yeah, I mean, I'm pretty sure it was right in this flat spot. This is all new. Think it's through there.
是的，我的意思是，我很确定它就在这片平地上。这一切都是新的。我想是在那边。
Because you have the stone wall.
因为你有那堵石墙。
Later, when I was packing to leave town, I found a small scrap of paper on the floor that had fallen out of the box of Nason stuff. There wasn't any writing on it, but I actually hesitated at the trash can. It's not that I missed my box of clues. I'd felt relief handing them over to Samantha. In fact, I actually felt lighter. But I was glad to have a remnant, however small, of the Nasons. So I took the scrap in my bag.
后来，当我收拾行李准备离开镇子时，我在地板上发现了一小张纸片，是从纳森东西盒子里掉出来的。上面没有任何字，但我确实对着垃圾桶犹豫了。并不是我怀念我的线索盒子。把它们交给萨曼莎时我感到解脱。事实上，我确实感觉轻松了。但我很高兴能拥有纳森一家的残余，无论多么小。所以我把这张纸片带进了我的包里。
Adam Beckman. In the years since we first broadcast this story, Adam worked as the cinematographer and co-director for our television show. It's streaming many places online. Three of the people that Adam interviewed for this story have died since it first aired, Gail Holmgren Bickford, one of the Freedom locals, Carol Chase, the former fire chief, and Mabel Davis, the woman that Adam talked to on a friend's front porch.
亚当·贝克曼。在我们首次播出这个故事后的几年里，亚当担任了我们电视节目的摄影师和联合导演。它在网上很多地方都有流媒体播放。亚当在故事中采访过的三个人在该节目首次播出后已经去世：盖尔·霍姆格伦·比克福德，其中一位弗里登当地人；卡罗尔·蔡斯，前消防队长；还有梅布尔·戴维斯，那个亚当在朋友前门廊上谈话的女人。
[MUSIC - "AMONG MY SOUVENIRS" BY THE CAROLINERS]
[音乐 - 卡罗琳人乐队演唱的《在我纪念品中》]
Our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Additional production help on the rerun from Aviva DeKornfeld, Jarrett Floyd, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to Carol Ford, Madeline Eldridge, Ron Beckman, and Jason Bittner.
我们今天的节目由温迪·多尔和我本人与亚历克斯·布隆伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩共同制作。今天节目的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。重播的其他制作协助来自阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、贾里特·弗洛伊德、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼。今天特别感谢卡罗尔·福特、马德琳·埃尔德里奇、罗恩·贝克曼和杰森·比特纳。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 650 episodes for absolutely free. Or you can download as many episodes as you want for extra convenient listening with the This American Life app. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里您可以完全免费流媒体播放我们超过650集的档案。或者您可以使用《美国生活》应用程序下载尽可能多的剧集以方便收听。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX发送给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who is fascinating. He describes one of his typical weekends this way.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他很迷人。他这样描述他典型的一个周末。
A teenage daughter returns late from a dance with a rose. She pins it to the mirror and hangs her dress in the closet. And then something horrible happens.
一个十几岁的女儿参加舞会晚归，拿着一朵玫瑰。她把它别在镜子上，把裙子挂在衣柜里。然后可怕的事情发生了。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。